[Music]
hi everybody oh thank you that's very
kind of you both um it's a pleasure to
be here thank you everybody for joining
us um we have a short session here so
I'm not going to take up uh too much of
your time but my job here is to set the
scene for what we would like to hear
these two illustrious gentlemen to
discuss so um what I would like to say
is that we will be discussing on the
edges of knowledge so the question is
what is it possible to know is the
physical Universe all there is or is the
immaterial part of reality too so we're
obviously joined by radical scientist
Rupert sheldrake and World leading
skeptic Michael Shermer um and they're
going to go head-to-head on the subject
of where the edges of knowledge lie
that's that's what we're here to do
I personally love the idea of you to
just having a full-on conversation and
we just get to spectate this but I've
been asked to get the conversation going
with a particular question and each of
you will get three minutes to sort of
set up your store and then we'll just go
from there how does that sound great
good all right so this is a question
what are the limits of human
understanding ruper I think you said
that Michael may go first how
gentlemanly of you Michael you're three
minutes no
pressure all right well what are the
limits of human knowledge how would I
know if I knew I would change my beliefs
or whatever we're stuck in the 21st
century and we know what we know so uh I
begin with the certican principle that
you know we're not special and I apply
it to myself I'm not special uh and so
I'm not God omniscient and omnipotent
you're not God either so we're in this
together or if you prefer the secular
version there is an objective reality
but I don't know what it is and you
don't either so we have to kind of
collectively go through what we know and
try to evaluate what we should believe
and I don't want to believe things that
have to be believed in to be true that
is reality is that which when you stop
believing in it doesn't go away as
Philip K dick said so that's our goal
and how do you get there well through
the tools of rationality and science you
know reason and arguments logic and
empiricism you actually go out there and
look out the window and see what the
world is actually like and see if it
matches your ideas which may or may not
be right and to the best that you can
collect data from out there to see if it
matches your ideas of what you think it
should be like and then try to hone
those so I guess it depends on the
particular topic of how confident we
could be in the current theories um the
theory of evolution you know is is over
150 years old now and it's pretty well
established but if we take a kind of a
basian approach by assigning some
probability of something being true true
with a small t or not somewhere between
one and 99 so the uh Cromwell principle
in basian reasoning Oliver Cromwell I
beseech you in the bows of Christ you
might be mistaken now he was talking
about some political issue but in basian
reasoning this is you never apply a zero
or a 100 to anything because you never
know it you may be wrong on this end you
may be wrong in this end so let's just
put so the theory of evolution you know
it's like 99% probably true with you
know fine-tuning if you're a Neo
darwinian or punctuated equilibrium or
some some little aspect of it uh but
it's not like the creationists are are
suddenly going to find something new
because they've been looking for a
century and a half and they haven't been
able to overturn the theory so uh it's
possible that Darwin was wrong probably
not and so we don't assign 100% to it we
always have an open mind just in case
and and you know the Big Bang Theory
probably true here's a whole pile of
evidence for it now it it's possible it
could be wrong and this could be
overturned probably not overnight
probably not one experiment's going to
overturn it uh it would have to be you
know a convergence of evidence to some
other theory that explains everything
The Big Bang Theory explains and these
other anomalies one of the problems we
face in all theories um is What's called
the residue of anomalies no Theory
explains everything so you always have
this residue of stuff that's not
explained and you have
so I use this example for UFOs uaps
you've seen these grainy videos and
blurry photographs what is that and the
pro ufologists say well we acknowledge
95% of all those sightings are fully
explicable by terrestrial phenomenon
geese and drones and Chinese spy
balloons so here we have this huge bin
of 95% and then you have the other
little bin it's aliens or it's the
Russian Chinese drones or whatever so
you have a new sighting which bin do you
put in it in well it's 95% likely to be
in this big bin so and it's you know 2
and half% for each of the two little
bins it might be there keep an open mind
just in case this is the one probably
not right so you know as we as the
saying goes if you hear foot hoofprints
outside think horse not zebra or I guess
here in Wales think
sheep not zebra I've seen a lot of sheep
here it's true so that's the approach
you know just uh you know just just
assign some probability to it I keep an
open mind with Rupert's ideas he might
be right uh but we'll see okay
well oh there we go there's a bit of
that rer can you can you tell us what
your thoughts are on on the limits of
human
understanding I think there are certain
intrinsic limits to understanding there
are certain things our minds may never
be able to grasp um I mean after all we
live in a cosmo 15 billion years old
with incredible number of galaxies and
so on it's it'd be very strange if human
Minds in the 21st century could grasp
all of it um but I agree with Michael
that one of the best methods we have is
science reason discussion evidence um we
don't disagree about that but where we
disagree is where we think the limits of
science are or should
be I think that there are many things
that we can investigate scientifically
which are at present to boo
uh within the academic and scientific
World um and those taboos are maintained
by organized groups of Skeptics and
Michaels as it were one of the
archbishops of the skeptic
movement um and um so uh and many
Skeptics U Patrol the frontiers of
knowledge and there are vigilante
skeptic squads set up all around the
world and Michael's trained many of them
he used to give
all he used to give workshops with the
late magician James Randy on how to be a
skeptic and I know that they're very
effective because their slogan was next
time a charlatan shows up in town be the
skeptic who the media ask you know their
opinion of and how can you be an expert
on this just say you are anyway I know
that CU when I show up in turn all these
trained Skeptics um feel that they ought
to cancel me because I'm doing research
that goes beyond the boundaries of what
they think science should be so this is
an issue that's not just an academic
issue it comes into it feeds into cancel
culture I had a TED Talk that was a Ted
X talk that was censored because it ran
F of some U pretty uh dogmatic
scientists um so I think that there are
Realms that we can investigate which are
at present almost impossible to study or
get funded within the University or
academic or scientific system I call
them the mysteries of everyday life um
some favorite skeptic slogan is
extraordinary claims demand
extraordinary evidence but I'm dealing
with ordinary claims 95% of people say
they've had the experience of being
looked at from behind turning around and
seeing someone looking at them the sense
of being stared at about 85% of people
say they've had the experience of what
seems like telephone telepathy thinking
of someone who then calls about 50% of
dog owners say their dog knows when a
knowers when a person member of the
family is coming home now these are
ordinary claims they're made by millions
of people and lots of people say they
happen on a regular basis they're not
weird strange things like Miracles that
happened 2,000 years ago they're
ordinary claims so can we look at them
scientifically for example
when people think someone's looking at
from behind is it because people turn
around all the time and occasionally
someone's looking at them and they think
aha there's some mysterious sense so or
is it more than that so you do
controlled experiments with randomized
trials uh in which people are looked at
or not looked at and they have to say
whether they're looked at or not in a
and and they're right or they're wrong
um and is it above chance the answer is
in many experiments there have been many
papers yes it
is it even seems to work through closed
circuit television people who work uh in
the surveillance industry are completely
convinced this is real we've interviewed
lots of private detectives security
officers surveillance officers The Drug
Squad at heo the store detectives at
herods um places people like that whose
job it is to watch others and in that
world there's almost no doubt this is
real because they see it all the time
yet move into the world of academic
science and the world the Citadel that's
defended by the uh the uh skeptic
movement patrolling the Frontiers and
this is just pseudo science doesn't
exist telephone telepathy is it just
coincidence do people think of others
all the time occasionally someone rings
when they're thinking of them they
imagine it's telepathy but they forget
all the millions of times they're wrong
well we do tests for potential callers
the person's filmed the whole time
landline phone a no caller ID we picked
the caller at random asked them to uh
ring the person their friend and when
the phone rings they have to guess which
of these four people it is before they
answer the phone by chance they'd be
right 25% of the time in our film trials
they right about 45% of the time
hundreds of Trials is very significant
dogs that know when their ERS are coming
home we film the dog we have people come
home at non-routine times uh they don't
know in advance traveling by unfamiliar
vehicles does the dog still go and wait
at the door 10 minutes or more before
the person comes home yes at least with
the dogs we've studied so I think the
evidence is quite strong these things
are real but if you try and do a PhD on
these things at a university except for
two or three exceptions most of them
here in Britain actually um you can't
because these are completely taboo
topics and these taboos are maintained
in force by active Skeptics so Michael's
a very nice chap you know he's friendly
he's funny um um but where he and
I I knew that would comeing where he and
I differ you see is that I think these
investigating things we don't understand
that we don't have necessarily a
theoretical explanation for is the very
essence of science to explore what we
don't know whereas some people well he
says he's open-minded let's say he is
but some of his colleagues are very
definitely not open-minded and uh they
just want to shut this down and and stop
what little investigation there is on
these subjects because it doesn't fit
their model of reality which is usually
the model of mechanistic materialism
that says the mind is nothing but the
brain and therefore all your thoughts
and intentions are inside the head so
how could they possibly affect a
distance these things are impossible
therefore the evidence for them is not
worth taking seriously or even looking
at now just I finish by saying that
that's not just a vague um accusation
Steven Pinker in his book rationality um
where he argues for a rational and
scientific approach says that there's no
need to look at the evidence for psychic
phenomena that is so improbable on
basian statistics grounds so incredibly
improbable it's a waste of time looking
at the evidence James OK a leading
member of the committee for skeptical
inquiry which is the one of the other
skeptic organizations Michael runs the
skeptic magazine they run the skeptical
Inquirer um our is the good
one well I subscribe to the skeptical
inquir actually
I I will I will make you an honorary
member of the skeptic
magazine well James OK who's one of
their most informed luminaries a
professor of psychology wrote a paper in
the American psychologist last year two
years ago saying exactly arguing that
that there's no need to look at the
evidence because these phenomena are
simply impossible therefore it's a waste
of time investigating them or looking at
the evidence now that in my opinion is
dogmatism which holds back science okay
first of
all first of of all let's debunk the
notion that these subjects are taboo and
you're not allowed to talk about them
here we are in a packed house talking
about these ideas you're one of the most
famous public intellectuals in the world
you have numerous best-selling books I
see you on TV all the time talking about
that who is censoring you nobody so
that's not what you mean you mean
mainstream scientists that you're trying
to convince are not convinced of your
evidence that's the real argument I
think you're making why is it that the
Steven Pinker myself or whoever don't
accept them now acknowledging that some
Skeptics are as you describe um uh but
there's often a good reason for that
because the evidence has not cumulated
enough converge to a particular
hypothesis that overturns the mainstream
Theory and and nudges us to accept that
is just not there and again it's not
that these things are taboo and no one
is doing this research as you know by
the way rert and I have a book called
arguing science you can order it on
Amazon uh in which we go back and forth
back and forth back and forth on all
these and most of the hypothesis he just
described staring at the back of the
neck the dog knows when the owner's
coming home and and so on have been
tested over and over they fail to
replicate most of the time not all the
time there may be an experiment or bias
so the most famous one here was the um
replication by Marilyn Schlitz and
Richard wisman Richard wisman is skeptic
Marilyn Schlitz is a Believer okay those
terms are problematic but whatever
they're kind of in those two different
camps and they each found different
results so okay where's the bias is it
on the part of the Skeptics to not
accept the data is it on the part of the
Believers to accept data that's not
sound well you just have to read the the
evidence and so you know like well here
I have these replicated experiments well
sort of but you know half of all Psych
experiments have not have failed to
replicate you know since the replication
Crisis began in 2008 not just your
research but half of all the most famous
psych experiments you've ever heard of
uh should have probably never been
published uh they were based on like one
experiment in which we alls we know is
the one that was published The
Experiment ran nine different
experiments eight of them found
non-statistically significant results
they published the one the Resco on the
file drawers called the fire file drawer
problem and so on this is very common
not just in psychical research but all
research right so acknowledging that
Pinker is is skeptical of half of these
psych experiment you you're standing at
the top of the escalator you give more
money than at the bottom of the
escalator or you have the power pose you
know if you put your shoulders back and
your chin up and so on your testosterone
goes up and this is what women should do
they should have the power pose when
they go that's what I was doing right
before we came in here I I noticed that
it was working I was intimidated no uh
that failed this was one of the most
famous Ted Talks there like 40 million
views of this power posed Ted Talk never
replicated so now the pink of the world
are skeptical of all that too not just
yours because of the failure to
replicate you know so it's not enough to
just have I have this one experiment in
which I found the statistically
significant result that's not enough you
have to have it replicated over and over
and over till it's really obvious and
almost everybody looking at it goes yeah
okay that that probably really happened
and you get kind of a consensus again
not 100% but just the majority like
climate consensus what does that mean
it's not a vote it's that most of the
scientists that study climate change
agree it's probably human caused so on
it's happening you know that kind of
thing well I we agree that most papers
in Psychology don't replicate most P
papers in biomedical science don't
replicate exactly but psychic
researchers were accused of this so
they've been subject to much more
scrutiny than any other branch of
science for much longer and in in
psychical research Arch um people
publish negative results and failed
replications in most of science they
don't or didn't until the replication
crisis and it's simply not true that
most these things don't replicate the
sense of being stared out has been
replicated many many times and even
Skeptics who've tried doing the
experiments most Skeptics don't do any
experiments but there's a few who do and
most of them got positive results when
they tried as um Susan Blackmore a
leading British skeptic did had a PhD
student they got positive results they
were never published and when I asked to
see the raw data they'd been lost
Richard wisman who did staring
experience got positive results first
time round when the students were doing
the staring so he replaced them with
himself as the sterer and then he got
the results he expected no effect in his
experiments with Marin Schlitz that
Michael referred to they were looking at
people through CCTV measuring whether
they could be uh whether their skin
resistance their emotional Ral changed
when they were being looked at at random
times uh through close circuit
television she um produced positive
effects they changed when she was
looking at them Richard wisman uh when
he was looking they didn't produce
positive effects now it's not
symmetrical she couldn't produce
positive effects in this just by wanting
to unless there was a real sense of
being stared at but he could produce
non-significant effects by not looking
very hard when he was when he was
interviewed afterwards he said was such
a boring experiment he you know he just
didn't look very hard so uh these are
not symmetrical um and so if you go into
this actual literature uh you'll find
that the idea it just doesn't replicate
is not true and the um sense of being
stared out been replicated telephone
telep has been replicated independently
at fryberg University in Amsterdam
University there's a much more
persuasive body of literature than
Michael's summary would lead you to
believe and the result of this is that
if you listen to Skeptics say oh it's
all inconclusive it's been replicated
all disputed Etc then what's the point
in going into the detailed literature
it's just seems like a waste of time
even though there is all this evidence
but the main reason I think uh for the
uh rejection or dogmatism or prejudice
against these uh phenomena by Prejudice
I mean prejudging uh the issue the main
reason is the materialist theory of mind
which is very much the belief system of
most card carrying Skeptics I know are
materialists for them the mind is the
brain and it's inside the head and it
shouldn't be able to do all these other
things um therefore the Prejudice is
much greater it's not just a matter of
evidence the same materialists are
perfectly happy to accept the theory of
physicist that there are quadrillions of
universes beside our own the Multiverse
Theory without one shred of evidence
dark matter and dark energy 95% of
reality physical reality just theories
no evidence at all except they make the
equations balanced so you can add in the
fudge factor of just as much as you like
titrate and as much dark energy to make
the equations of physics balance to
explain the universe as it is and that
doesn't provoke anger or or or or
attacks from most Skeptics uh physicists
have a get out of jail free card for but
as soon as you come to anything that
challenges the central belief the mind
is nothing but the brain and therefore
there's no consciousness out there in
the universe there's no God there's
nothing uh Beyond uh Consciousness
limited to human and animal brains and
possibly the brains of
extraterrestrials then when you
challenge that worldview that's where
the problem kicks in and almost no
amount of evidence is going to be enough
uh because we're dealing here with a
fixed belief system highly AED by
confirmation
bias should I well I I just wanted to
say so what for the for the audience's
sake so I I'm also a scientist I'm a I'm
a researcher I work in the bench and
what's remarkable about this
conversation that we're seeing unfolding
is of course there's multiple subjects
but the central point is um
about what is evidence whose evidence do
you believe and therefore what
constitutes actual knowledge right and
this is the type of ation that happens
regardless of whether or not you're
talking about a particular phenomenon
within a cell or whether we're talking
about the kind of phenomena that the rer
is discussing here so um I think
actually there's a really big subject
happening and that we're touching upon
here about basically knowledge and and
who whose knowledge is what is knowledge
but the evidence provided by different
people and who do you choose to believe
right yeah yep that's the hard part so
you know again it's a it's a social
community of people that work uh in a
field and you know there then there are
the people that are kind of on the
margins and then the people that are way
out here and so you know Rupert and I
both get these uh alternative theories
of physics there's hundreds of them like
you know you get them every week and you
know what do you do with those and why
don't they have a platform here well
which ones and so the mainstream
scientists sort of by necessity have to
think well they're probably in the
little bins that are not going to likely
to pan out so we have to kind of
concentrate on the you know the
mainstream and the just the few
challenges from maybe some I don't know
Renegade scientists or whatever they're
here I mean there's several people here
that are challenging the dark energy
Dark Matter the big bang and so on I've
heard them and they're not Fringe
they're not tinfoil hat wearing whacka
Doodles they're like professors they're
like real Scholars okay so again where's
the censorship they they are out there
they are CH there are books about String
Theory as just being complete
so and I get them all the time so what's
where's the censorship the problem is
that you want those those kind of
anecdotal or Fringe or challenging ideas
to become the mainstream why aren't they
and I would argue you just haven't made
the case strong enough because it is an
extraordinary claim in a sense saying
that you know 400 years of
physics is wrong because because i' ran
this experiment in which somebody could
detect somebody staring at the back of
their neck or the BAM experiment of
subjects looking at computer screens
trying to guess which side the erotic
image was going to pop up versus the
neutral image left or right uh and you
know and you bem ran nine experiments
this one gets published 53 you know 5050
but 53% of the images that were erotic
you know basically pornography were
detected by college students you know
more than the neutral image right so
when bam goes on the the co bear report
he called this extra sensory por
Inception right and that you know so
what's more likely that 400 years of
physics is wrong because some social
scientists showed porn pictures to
college students or he's just mistaken
in there there's some eror he made he
just screwed up the methodological
problems right so before you overthrow
the 400 years of physics maybe we should
look this one a little more carefully
and really make sure it replicates over
and over and over before you throw out
the big Theory there that's my response
well that's a rhetorical argument I've
heard many times Michael um well thank
you over hearing for overthrowing 400
years of physics I mean you know I Susan
Blackmore for example used this against
me on in an article she wrote in the
times educational supplement what's more
likely that 400 years of physics the
whole edifice of science all modern
techn technology mobile phones TV all of
that is wrong or that chel Drake's right
you know that is a false opposition damn
I thought I came up with that
argument that was Susan's argument the
the original nobody's saying 400 years
of physics is wrong except for some
physicists who are right here in hon way
um um the I'm certainly not saying that
what I'm saying is that mechanistic
materialism the dominant or Orthodoxy or
Paradigm of science for more than a 100
years is that it's very weakest dealing
with Consciousness and mind price
precisely because it denies that
Consciousness is anything but the
activity of matter and its least
successful areas are to do with minds
and they're the least understood things
really that's why Consciousness studies
is such an important field in science
now the last 20 years or so because we
understand oddly enough least of all
about the nature of our own minds and we
don't even know the extent of our minds
um and so it's not as if physicists have
actually studied the nature of
Consciousness or Minds they've studied
Quantum particles and Galactic movements
and or planetary orbits and the behavior
of electrons so the fact that physicists
haven't studied these subjects at all it
means that physics is almost irrelevant
to this question there may be properties
of Minds that go beyond beond anything
that physicists study in Quantum
particles have fund just as there are
properties of Life uh that go beyond
what physicists would but
rert Roger Penrose is here he's one of
the greatest scientists of all time he
wrote a book about the hard problem of
Consciousness being somehow explained by
these Quantum Fields inside the
microtubules of neurons and so on his
whole theory that you I think would be
uh attracted to CU he's challenging the
mainstream and he's a f so what are you
talking about well his theory of quantum
nonlocality he applies quantum theory to
Consciousness uh but he confines it to
microtubules which are small mole
macromolecular structures inside nerve
cells and I think the mind is extended
far beyond the brain I think my image of
you is located where you're sitting not
inside my head I don't think there's a
little Michael inside my head I think my
interview is projected out to where you
are yeah and because it's projected out
if I were looking at you from behind and
you didn't know I was there it might
affect you because it's projected out
and I did once say to Roger Penrose you
believe that Consciousness is extended
but why stop at sort of 10 microns
inside the micr tubu uh why not let it
extend for hundreds of yards or even
miles uh when we're looking at distant
things and he hadn't really got an
answer to that he only said you've got
to start
somewhere I mean that's a as good an
answer as
[Laughter]
any um but you know if you look up just
look under Wikipedia of hard problem of
Consciousness there's like two dozen
theories right so you have one Roger
Penrose has one but they're not the only
ones and none of them have convinced the
majority of neuroscientists and so on
that that's the right one so what do you
do well you just wait let's just keep
trying to figure it out so we we don't
have very long left in the debate
unfortunately
but in these last 5 minutes I actually
want to pick up exactly where you just
uh left that which is all right so of
course even academic science is the
pursuit of many different theories and
some theories are less likely but there
are many things that we now hold to be
true the classic one of course being
that we are in a solar system going
around the Sun that used to be a fringe
idea right that was very much to the
edge of of academic acceptance um and
now it's just true so here's my question
and for the last sort of few minutes of
this debate how how is it that ideas go
from being an idea to being tested to
actually becoming accepted and of course
evidence is a big part of it I'm a
scientist so I would say that but also
you know we all kind of have that Human
Experience of knowing that popular
opinion tends to also sort of seep in on
occasion you know even when talking
about scientific theories we'll be like
oh well you know everyone sort of agrees
on this one right so what what happens
in that uncomfortable interface between
actual evidence and the fact that we are
sort of susceptible to what everyone
else thinks and how does sort of the
prevailing knowledge and Dogma come into
to formation through those two
interfaces well that is that is the hard
question it's kind of a sociology of
Science question or a history of Science
question and it really so it's a burden
of proof argument who has the burden of
proof you know the mainstream person to
to to uh refute your arguments or the is
the burden on you and you end up with
this what Dan Dana calls burden tennis
you no the burden is on you whack no the
burden is on you no whack and everybody
has their data sets and just just
different field say climate Skeptics
there's a lot of them in America you may
have heard and so they write me all the
time and they they they want to know why
the climate Community won't accept their
alternative theories of global warming
that it's not human cause it's volcanoes
or sunspots or whatever and and the
answer is is because a you're not a
climate scientist you know you're a
lawyer or whatever and and you're not
publishing in mainstream climate
journals you don't go to climate
conferences you don't know anybody that
works in the field and your evidence
isn't very good so the burden is on you
to convince all these climate scientists
you've got some viable alternative and
they haven't done that and this is where
this 97% figure 97% of climate
scientists say well that just comes from
a sort of study of the abstracts of
10,000 papers on climate science and the
the 3% are over here and they go well I
have all my alternative theories but
they don't converge to anything that
would overthrow you know the
anthropogenic theory of climate CH okay
so that's it and that's true for all
Fields it's just that's just the way it
goes you're not the only one there's a
bunch of people with alternative
theories of Consciousness and so on and
they haven't convinced everybody so too
bad keep
working well I mean you're you're
basically your position is basically one
of
conservatism you're a scientific
conservative not politically what no not
political conserv no doubt a social
liberal we haven't discussed that
but but scientific conservatism
basically what the authorities say
what's published in nature and science
what gets funded by the National Science
Foundation that's science and that's
really part of the Paradigm or or
sociological aspect that yeah Ganesh
said talked about the what Thomas
showed in his famous book on stru the
structure of scientific revolutions is
it's not just about evidence and reason
and logic it's to do with what is
collectively a collective belief system
at a given time and if you have really
good evidence that doesn't fit into that
system it'll be ignored or treated as an
anomaly or marginalized and then a
scientific revolution occurs which
incorporates these anomalies like in the
early 20th century when the idea of
Continental drift was first put forward
because if you look at the globe the
continents fit together and they might
have drifted apart when vean and prod
produced that idea it was ridiculed for
decades until a mechanism was found and
then it's now it's the standard view
plate tectonics um there have been many
cases where in the 18th century when
people found hot Stones falling from the
skies they were denounced by the
scientific authorities as being
credulous peasants because there
couldn't be Stones falling from the sky
because there are no stones in the sky
we now know they're meteorites and and
and and and so on so um it depends
really on a larger consensus change and
I think we are actually on the threshold
of a change a larger change which would
and part of it would be a change that
includes Consciousness as part of our
model of reality instead of
marginalizing it as to an epip
phenomenon of the brain and when that
happens I think we'll have a much
broader view it will lead to KnockOn
effects in say areas like medicine where
at present official medicine in
mechanistic medicine physics and
chemistry surgery and drugs there are
many alternative therapies um and if we
um have a broader more holistic
worldview then I think we not I'm not
suggesting we accept every claim of
every therapy but we could have as there
already is it to some degree in the
United States comparative effectiveness
research finding out what works and it
may be some of these therapies work as
well or better than traditional uh
mechanistic medicine and then Skeptics
will say well it's just the placebo
effect but then say well okay that's
really interesting the placebo effect is
itself a healing modality and and if one
treatment can unleash more placebo
effect than another it may work better
so we can open up a whole new way of
thinking instead of just closing down
here in Britain the medical research
Council as far as I know funds no
research on alternative or complimentary
medicine um it focus is more on you know
mechanistic medicine and um so I think
this world viw which would I think it'll
also be propelled by political factors
because mechanistic materialism which
treats the whole earth as in a devoid
inanimate Etc underlies the exploitative
model we have of nature it's led to the
great imbalance between humanity and
nature uh that itself the the political
the climate crisis uh will I think force
a change in the way we think I think
we're on the threshold of a a major
shift in Consciousness in which the
kinds of anomalies I've been talking
about that don't fit into the
mechanistic picture will become part of
a new world model now I'm someone
rooting for that Michael's on the other
side saying you know just keep it works
well enough as it is let's keep things
as they that's a bit unfair surely I'm
putting words into your mouth Michael is
What's called the Survivor survivorship
bias that is he just gave examples where
the scientists turn out to be wrong and
the alternative theorists turn out to be
right PL tectonics with continental
drift and meteorites and so on but what
about the 10,000 alternative theories
that turn out not to be right where are
those people no one writes biographies
of them all the alternative people think
they're Galileo going up against the
church but most of the people in the
past several centuries that were had
these alternative the they were wrong
and that's why we never hear about them
well as is always the case in these
situations we really don't have enough
time please can you put your hands
together in in thanks to our wonderful
speakers thank
you